i've had the fortune
of being a wrestler and i would draw a
distinction between
a very well executed and competition
double leg single leg takedown or a pin
there's some as an ocd person there's
something so
comforting about a well executed pin
because it's like two seconds and it's
just like
everything is flush and nice and it like
it's all clean
i mean okay is this ocd person who likes
to align
show it's just beautiful okay that's
good technique
wrestling also provides you
maybe more than other sports the feeling
of
dominating another human yes of breaking
no
not just of them being very cocky and
very powerful you feel this power of
another human being
and then you breaking them and like
i'm not as honest as mike tyson but
that's
that uh uh i don't think i've ever
sort of looked in the mirror and said
like that that was
in i enjoyed that aspect of it but it
certainly seems like you chased that
so when i was a wrestler in high school
um
i lost so many matches because of over
aggressiveness um like you know i would
pick the top position and let you stand
just so that i could do a matte return
and i wasn't trying to return you to the
mat
i was actually trying to like drive you
through the mat and through the ground
like i
took like i it gave me joy to do that
yeah
like it wasn't like i was trying to you
know just return you to the mat so that
i could pin you
that what you just talked about like the
the dominating another person i used to
look at that as
you've got someone who in theory is
equally trained and equally skilled as
you are
and you're you're absolutely out there
totally dominating them
there's joy in that you could get in an
mma fight and you could
take someone down and you can mount them
and
all that feels great but when you start
raining down the punches on their face
from mount and like dropping elbows and
stuff like there's another level of
satisfaction there
and it's it's tough to describe and i
don't think that
it's everyone uh is made for it when
i was a i think when i was a senior in
high school my wrestling coach said look
you've got to stop with all this crazy
aggressive
wrestling like they try to turn me into
a technician
and and it and it did work to a degree
and it was a humongous shift for me in
terms of success
but it wasn't the same level of
enjoyment out of it
um like i mean i got disqualified from
new england because my coach said
crossface and i cross-faced and he said
harder and i basically wound up and
blasted a kid in the face and his
nose got you know busted everywhere but
i didn't think not to do it because that
felt good
it felt good to cross-face him like that
i was that was a lot of like
that's a weird american warrior ethos
that i've
picked up but i also have them either
the russian the city of brothers that
don't see it
don't see it as that they don't get draw
they think that there is a tension
between the art
of the martial art and the violence of
the martial art
i agree with that it's a poetic way i
could put it but they're not so
fascinated with this dan gable
dominating another human
they think uh the effortlessness the
effortlessness
of the technique and your mastery of the
art is exhibited in its effortlessness
how much you lose yourself in the moment
and the timing that just the beauty of
the timing
like there's much more like one example
in judo but also in wrestling
you can look at the foot sweep wrestlers
in america and even judo players in
america
much of the world don't admire the
beauty of the foot sweep
but a well-timed foot sweep which is a
way to sort of off balance to find the
right timing to just
effortlessly uh change
the tape turn the tables of uh
dominate your opponent is is seen as the
highest form
of mastery in in russian wrestling and
in case of judos and in japanese judo
it's interesting i'm not sure i'm not
sure what what that tension is about
i think it actually takes me back to
i don't know if you listen to uh dan
carl in hardcore history and genghis
khan if you've
ever i've read a great great book
on jen's car yeah i'm so i'm still
trying to adjust
most of my life said genghis khan but uh
the right pronunciation is uh
actually changus khan
there's a tension there we kind of think
i don't know we
i kind of thought as genghis khan is a
ultra violent a leader of
ultraviolent men but another view
another way to see them is the people
who warriors that
valued extreme competence and mastery of
the art
of uh fighting with weapons with bows
with the horse riding all that kind of
stuff
and i'm not sure exactly where to place
them
on my sort of thinking about violence in
in our human history i think in
the context of like combat sports i
think there's a difference between an
athlete winning a contest under a
certain set of rules
and a fighter winning a fight under
those exact same rules
there's a different approach to it and i
don't think
one is any better than the other like
in mma i think a great example would be
george st pierre george st imperial is a
tremendous
it's a tremendous athlete and he
considers himself to be a martial artist
first
he's trying to win an athletic
competition like
nick diaz is trying to bust your ass
yeah right there's a different
approach to it and yes they've had
different results at the highest level
of competition
but it's difficult to attribute the
difference in results
just to their approach to the sport
because they're different human beings
with different abilities and different
different
uh physical attributes um
the scitea brothers have that luxury of
being able to talk about the beauty of a
perfectly timed slide by right there are
other wrestlers that will never be able
to pull that off
and therefore they have to pursue other
ways to defeat someone and maybe it is
the dan gable
breaking a man's spirit by outworking
him type thing which
is beautiful in its own way uh but
we we we tend to self-select the ways in
which we're able to be successful
and then kind of take a deep dive into
that what do you think is more beautiful
brute force or
effortless execution
of uh technique that dominates another
human
i think it's a subjective thing based on
what skills you perceive yourself to
have
i'm never i've never been a slick uh
super
athletic dexterous competitor in
anything
and i've always been more of an i've
gotta outwork you i've gotta out grind
you i gotta help mean you
and so because i've lived that i tend to
see the beauty in that more because i
have a perceptual awareness
that i don't have for the people who
have the luxury of being very slick and
athletic and
and using beautiful technique now that
said there's a phenomenal
little video the other day i sent to a
friend
of a compilation of foot sweeps by leota
machida
in mma and they're so beautiful and
they're so awesome
and it's not that i don't have an
appreciation for those
but i can't emulate those because i lack
the physical
ability to do that whereas i
i at least have a chance to emulate some
of the people who
do it through grit and throughout
working people
you